how did you feel walking around the
exhibition what do you think of it it's
fantastic it's it's surprising no I mean
I've been living in it for like three
years
so so I mean it's great but you know I
first came a few days when I came back
from Cuba and came here and to see it
but I mean I've been skyping in it that
I'm putting it up again um oh that's
never going to work God change it but we
know been living with it virtually for
for a year now you know in the planning
of it
each room how the rooms are going to be
laid out so it's not like a brief
surprise that'd be really odd um have
you felt have you enjoyed the process of
looking back the nostalgia no it's not
really been my kind of roll a bit the
best I'm going to get you anywhere
um my role in it is to be is is to you
know to make it as a fun and interesting
experience as possible and to make it
irreverent and funny and and of course
it's nostalgic in some way but that's
not the immediate emotion that you know
my thing is to try and get it to be a
fun thing and it is this for the punter
that's gonna walk in the room is this
interesting you know that's what I'm
asking is as fun as this interesting is
this is boring and check that out or you
don't know me so that's to me to me
anything is to make it cuz it's not you
don't really have that much to to go on
for this kind of exhibition I mean
there's also exhibitions and art
installations and yeah there's been the
David Bowie one which I never saw sad to
say and there's the big one at MoMA in
New York and I went to the Abba museum
but that's like it it's not just about
your music it's about so much more the
art the collaboration yeah and how
important is all of that mean it's it's
all of its yeah as you say I mean the
the clothes of course it you know you
people really like to look at clothes
you know I've got an incredible amount
the only thing I kept from all this time
is really the clothes and some guitars
and the rest of our chats away but
there's lots again there's film there's
art posters there's your videos the of
course music and
and then personal things and just quirky
things and so I think that's what we try
to do try to to make it a good
combination of all these things stayed I
forgot stages you know there's a good
thing about you know staging 3d and I
think yeah absolutely
I'm glad you like that what is it like
being on stage because I mean it just
must be so addicted no wonder you never
want to give it up most like a drug oh
yeah I mean I like to think I can live
without it but photo no I mean just
coming back from last weekend doing
cuber in front of I don't know how many
hundred thousand people a lot of people
anyway yeah I mean it's it's good and
then you see at the end of this
exhibition you see this one from High
Park like this and the 3d one song from
Hyde park's it kind of puts you in the
music plays or concert place you know
it's good you just described qiblas good
it must have been more than that I mean
was it nice I think because it's very
starting for them because you know they
never had a really big concept you know
they have Major Lazer like the light
show kind of an a dance thing that a
couple weeks before they had some
concept but this is this is like a big
rock concert then everybody had that so
that was a lot of hard but it was it was
really a lot of work in them and there's
a lot of obstacles you know as an
obstacle course to give this concert and
then you know between your merit because
all a lot of our stuff going from the
United States and had to be there is
there was no infrastructure really so we
had to bring it all from Miami so when
we started out it was all between it was
all about getting the permits from the
United States and the poets and Kira's
like bureaucracy Ganassi crackers and
you can't get away from the politics of
doing the politics of it yeah and then
we were supposed to do it on the 20th of
March and then Obama decided to go there
he wanted to go there in the 20th so who
is that we were like that trying to
change those schedules around for the
hand-sew so we had to do it later and
that was Good Friday and then finally
the Vatican objected to Good Friday like
two days before me said no sorry we
can't hey we're doing anyway so it is up
until the last minute it was
fantastic obstacle course and a lot of
people work very very hard at making her
and I mean talking about the politics of
it I mean how important was that side of
it yeah I mean I think between all these
different things that were going on in
Cuba for you know for I mean I went
there just before Christmas or holiday
and a little bit of a look-see and so on
I mean politically it was a sort of
social and cultural event you know I
mean Obama speech was very political and
I thought a very interesting and
informative speech and he said a lot of
things they wouldn't say in China but
similar sort of things and and then you
know a few days later we come with the
kind of social cultural thing and which
brings a very huge amount of people to
just have you know to sort of show that
there's a changing society I mean it's
not going to change overnight because
the rawness does right there but it's
it's a very gradual thing that's
changing of society like that you are as
a band one of Britain's kind of best
cultural exports you've become British
ambassador's and I mean we decided if
you're gonna vote to stay in Europe or
not that's not a risk Oh question I I
think it's a really complex question and
I and I said this in answer to and I
wonder if David Cameron if he was asked
today whether he'd actually want to put
this out for a referendum now but but
it's but it is it is a complex question
and it affects people in different ways
in you know we're not all were not all
affected by it in in the same way and
you know some people running a big
company there I read a story that
yesterday or today are saying we're
going to affect me and my company but
I'm sure there's some companies it would
really affect and so you know everyone's
affected by it in different ways
economically and a lot of its emotion as
well you know it all out come on I'm
hedging you a lot of position of it to
me I don't think to me personal
like really personally it is going to
make a huge difference and those people
here today be saying we will never see a
band like the stones ever again there's
so much talent out there but why do you
think I don't know but I don't leave
that and and then and someone said to me
Oh were they no one else could do an
exhibition like this what not right now
no but I mean maybe not not right now I
mean but I'm sure there'll be other
people just as good in what not better
than us that will do better exhibitions
and I hope so anyway because you know
don't be the only one and you know just
we we were one of the first bands to do
lots and lots of things we did we do
first and that's great and I think we
were the first band to do cover maybe
not the first artist to do an exhibition
like this but the first band to do one
maybe on this scale so yeah so we love
doing that but we hope other people do
it after us and how do you keep that
passion how do you keep that spark of
the early days it she's still obviously
gone I think by just doing occasionally
these dark things you know like doing
Cuba and you know really working at it
where other people might have given up
you know and in taking on something like
this which you don't really have to do
but it's it's interesting it's fun it's
sort of a different challenge you know
and I think all those things make it
interesting but obviously have to do the
you know meat potatoes part of it which
is singing dancing and have you still
got the rebellion because there were
those brilliant headlines over there
look at your daughter's the stones are
coming look at your grandmother's now
they're saying yeah does it make you
laugh now you've got kids and grandkids
that that was written about you know
when I was did the show in the southern
United States and there was a poster
outside this College this it said Mick
Jagger slept with your grandmother it's
a joke so it's quite funny really
and it was Deventer some sort of joke
because it was a college game you know
for like 20 year olds basically 2000
audience but
but anyway you can laugh about it yeah
they suck in love yeah I'm fine I mean
do you think that if you this is a
bizarre question but if you were women
do you think you'd be going this long
which is also ah if you were a woman do
you think it's a difficult gender
question could you you know do you think
if you here's a girl band yeah would you
be my scale would you be rocking this
song if it is the Spice Girls doing this
you for money
well you vote for awesome I don't ask me
ask them they're gonna do a turn next
year else then maybe you could hook up
thank you so much jános brilliant thank
you thank you thanks very much